So far, as we’ve journeyed through the microcosmos,
the organisms we’ve shown you are mostly aquatic.
You might find them in oceans or rivers or
lakes, finding their own niche in their watery ecosystem.
And surrounding them, dissolved in the water,
is always oxygen, which is essential to their survival.
But as you travel down and find where water
meets sediment, a transition occurs.
Yes, from more liquid to more solid, but more importantly, the sediments
impede the movement of oxygen.
Which means that, as oxygen gets consumed
by living organisms, the concentration goes down.
The transition here is, in many ways, even
more distinct than the transition from the
land to the sea in our macro-world.
Yes, it is difficult for fish to live out
of water, and hard for us to live in it, but
ultimately, fish and humans are both based
on roughly the same metabolic chemistry.
We both rely on oxygen.
But here at this transition, where the environment
goes from oxic, meaning there is oxygen, to
anoxic, meaning there isn’t, life’s metabolic
chemistry fundamentally shifts.
It’s muddy there.
Slimy, a little smelly, maybe even a little
gross, but to many organisms, the oxic anoxic
transition is a shifting chemical boundary
that has created a challenge for life...a
challenge that changed it’s nature, a challenge
it conquered.
So let’s talk about the organisms that prefer
an environment void of oxygen, because many
of them will end up shaping the world around
the organisms that live along this transition.
Now we’re not quite sure, but we believe
this long, large, tightly-coiled bacterium
is a type of spirochete, many of which prefer
to live without oxygen.
They come up often in these mud samples and
you might know some of their kind as the more
familiar, and less welcome organisms that
cause syphilis and Lyme disease.
And just to note, this video is not sped up—the
organism really moves like this.
Spirochete’ are uniquely motile, able to
move around even in thick, viscous substances.
To vastly oversimplify the entire basis of
our life as we know it, oxygen’s big, important
role is to accept electrons in the chemical
processes that make our cells go and our existence
possible, so, thanks oxygen.
But organisms that live in anoxic environments
substitute oxygen with other chemicals.
Some, like this ciliate Caenomorpha, are found
in environments rich in oxygen’s downstairs
neighbor on the periodic table, sulfur, along
with bacteria that thrive in a sulfuric world.
Now these look like vibrating, hyperactive
worms, but they’re actually bacteria, specifically
a purple sulfur bacteria, these are Thiospirillum.
Inside the Thiospirillum are little globules
where they stock sulfur for later use.
They’re photosynthetic and they often prefer
anoxic environments.
These bacteria use various forms of sulfur
to produce their energy—including, in the
case of thiospirillum, those sulfur stores.
In these kinds of sulfuric sediments, you’ll
find concentrations of sulfur and oxygen as
opposing gradients.
As you descend into sediment, the concentration
of oxygen decreases, consumed by the life
that depends on it.
Meanwhile, sulfide diffuses upwards from the
anoxic microbes below, and as you travel further
down, the sulfur concentration increases as
you get closer to its source.
But in that sediment is a layer where oxygen and sulfur co-exist.
This is the oxic-anoxic interface, a several
100 uM thick boundary that attracts bacteria
like these Achromatium oxaliferum, a large
sulfur bacteria found in freshwater and salt
marsh sediments that comes up often in our
mud samples.
Similar to Thiospirillum, Achromatium has
small sulfur globules.
But the bacteria is also able to roll upwards
through the sediment in what seems to be a
response to the presence of oxygen, suggesting
that it might take up oxygen as well.
Currents in the water and various other changes
in the environment can affect where the oxic-anoxic
interface is, so Achromatium and other bacteria
that thrive in this layer need the ability
to sense and move in response to the shifting
oxygen and sulfur layers.
These gradient roving Achromatium have so
far been difficult to grow in large quantities
in a lab, perhaps because their natural environment
and the relationships they have with their
surrounding microbes are just too complicated.
As a result, these bacteria remain mysterious
giants.
Their bodies contain sizable stores of calcite,
but we don’t know what they’re for.
Some scientists have guessed that they might
help control the acidity of the cell, while
others have suggested it might help regulate
the cell’s buoyancy.
There are many theories, including that the
amount of calcite inside Achromatium makes
them off-putting to predators.
Now, we don’t know if that’s the case
with this Loxodes magnus, which is valiantly
trying and failing to eat this Achromatium.
We did observe it for a while, and it kept
rejecting the giant bacterium, so at the very
least, there seems to be something unappetizing
about them.
Here with some Achromatium, is a fellow interface
bacteria Macromonas, moving around with the
use of its flagella.
Macromonas seem to also keep a sulfide stock
in little globules, and they’re distinguished
by inclusions where they store calcium oxalate,
which may help the cell keep up its metabolism
even when the conditions around it aren’t
good.
You can see the inclusions in this clip here—the
larger those calcium oxalate stores are, the
slower the bacteria moves.
There is, of course, so much more to the story
of mud and microbes.
The oxidations and the reductions.
The various forms of the sulfurs and the oxygens,
not to mention the carbons and nitrogens that…we
did not even mention.
It’s messy, and we don’t mean muddy...we
mean, complicated.
As you might have noticed, oxygen is pretty
important to biochemical mechanisms.
We can live weeks without food, days without
water, but only moments without oxygen.
And metabolic systems on this planet evolved
largely in the presence of this marvelous,
versatile, and common electron acceptor.
Without it, everything changes.
Every balance has to be re-weighted.
Every gradient shifted.
And yet when you step back and look at these
anoxic environments, everything seems to come
together in a muddy elegance.
One gradient gives way to another, one process
swaps out for another.
And the microcosmos distributes itself accordingly.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Journey to the Microcosmos is produced by
Complexly.
If you want to keep imagining the world complexly
with us, we have a bunch of other things.
We’re producing a Crash Course on Artificial
Intelligence right now, hosted by Jabril Ashe.
Over 20 episodes, we’ll going to unpack
the logic behind AI systems, and even write
and implement code in labs.
Check out the first video about the history
of artificial intelligence and the revolution
that is happening today!
There's a link in the description.
If you want to see more from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
there's always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.